you have a vision to have
basically meat in every store that comes
from a a farm like belcampo
that's uh that's basically doing
regenerative farming
how do we get there it's about a network
of smaller producers
working together with shared values
and it's
true there's a limit on regenerative
farming in that
it requires more human knowledge so
regenerative farming is more difficult
to scale
in a single operation it'd be really
challenging to have a regenerative farm
that was like 200
000 acres because of the amount of
manpower
needed to pay attention can you first
and i apologize to interrupt but
can you say what is regenerative farming
sure
so they if you're looking at scaling
regenerative farming
it's a traditional system of agriculture
regenerative farming is how we used to
farm
we used to farm with an eye towards the
long term
you might be on the friedman farm
thinking about your heirs
five generations from now farming that
same land
are you going to leave that land
nutritionally empty
no okay so long-term thinking also
in traditional ag you don't have inputs
that are very convenient
you can put some chicken manure on but
you can't
spray or dump something that massively
increases
the growing potential of the land
that was not available until the past 60
years
so regenerative agriculture is
an approach to farming where you're
increasing soil fertility
through your farming you increase soil
fertility
by feeding the soil you feed the soil
through carbon that's why regenerative
farming is better for the environment
it sequesters carbon and puts carbon
into the soil
now it's interesting plants
need carbon and put it into the soil
when they're going through growth
so if you have a beautiful field of
grass that's just waving in the wind
that's not sequestering as much carbon
as plants that have been damaged
and are regrowing plants that have been
damaged and are re-growing
are repairing and they're doing that by
drawing down carbon as one of the
nutrients that feeds them
to damage the plants effectively that's
what we're doing with regenerative
grazing
so the cows or you know lambs whatever
out there they're eating and taking
the grass down and that then cause a
regrowth cycle
that sequesters carbon wow there's a
limit to it there's an edge
because if those plants are so damaged
that they can't regrow
then it turns into a dirt patch and that
doesn't sequester any carbon
so it's a balance how do you find that
balance so
that has to do with like the frequency
and the scale the grazing essentially
exactly and so you have to find the
right balance and that that connects to
the
both the the grass i mean is is the
ultimately
the focus here is then the life cycle of
whatever is grazing whether it's cows
or lambs or so on that's why the
scalability question so all that stuff
that i
just talked about like think about all
the actions that that requires
somebody's out there looking and paying
attention
and understanding how far the grass is
remembering what happened in that field
last year
there's a huge human intelligence need
and human
kind of a availability of attention
now industrial farming has done a great
job at de-skilling
agriculture
industrial farming has taken agriculture
from being art science to being
entry-level employment yeah
so that's the limiting factor on regen
and that's why i think the human
intelligence
you